[Music]
week one you were to stand down favorite
it's very difficult to do to go through
the whole season and come out on top I
mean congratulations Batali how does it
feel that it's officially over and
you're holding in your hands it's really
surreal to be honest I feel like we both
put so much work and so much love and
then this whole season and into every
dance that we did and we both really put
everything that we had on the floor and
to be able to be validated for that
feels amazing we see you know obviously
the physical journey that the dancing
we're talking about the emotional
journey from the beginning of this
season the end is it seemed like it was
a very emotional season it definitely
was I feel like I'm a completely
different person than when I started and
I know that I'm a better person for all
of this and I'm just I'm happy to be
here I'm so happy that I took this
journey and then I got to go on it with
him and that we get to stand here
together and hold this you said many
times that this was you know the most
incredible experience of your life
what is it about Dancing with the Stars
that makes it such you know powerful
experience I don't think that there's
any other scenario really in the world
that's like this where you're put into a
situation where you are dancing with
someone who's been doing it their entire
lives and
every week you're put in a crazy
scenario but you have to step up and I
think it really shows and reveals what
kind of person you are you it's it's the
honesty that we have about being behind
the camera and the rehearsals and all of
it it's just you have to really be ready
to lay yourself on the floor where you
gonna keep the Mirrorball trophy vomit
look yeah what's up by my bed by your
gun oh hey you think you're gonna have
to like you know fight your parents off
yeah they're gonna want to try and like
uh take it from I doubt it no no
you